related to social and demographic
research they are Alan day fo and Beth
Noveck our first speaker will be Alan
day fo assistant professor of political
science at Yale University and faculty
fellow at buzzy institution for social
and Policy Studies and the Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies professor Dave hos research
examines the causes of war and
statistical methods for credible causal
inference he won the Lemur Rosenthal
prize for open social science and
emerging and as an emerging researcher
for his work improving transparency
practices his PhD in political sciences
from the University of California
Berkeley and he has an MA from in
economics from Berkeley and an
undergraduate degree from mcmaster
university so welcome professor Dafoe
thanks so much so the real pleasure to
have Brian just share with us all the
fantastic tools that they're building in
many ways much of what i normally would
say to a typical audience i am going to
skip through because i think both this
audience is more expert and in these
topics and also brian covered a sort of
a lot of motivation and sort of overall
philosophy about transparency that i
would otherwise say so transparency is
crucial to science science to the public
enterprise right we need to make
knowledge claims that are then
interrogated in a public manner but it's
not just public it's also requires that
I trust that the claims that the
community has accepted or that are sort
of in some level of regard and esteem
are reliable the the mechanisms of
science have to help me know what claims
I can rely on them which ones I can't
otherwise I have to sort of review every
argument that I might want to cite or
method I want to build on and that's
just not practical but unfortunately we
know from cases of fraud and just
neglect and turn on reproducible results
and in particular from the systematic
study that of 100 replications in
psychology that on the order of maybe
twenty to fifty percent of say
experimental results do not reproduce in
the sense that they might be there might
be no result there right it's actually
zero and the original result was a
scientist finding noise or the results
is much weaker than the initial
publication okay so sciences we're
trying to build this edifice but it's
only as good as the materials that are
coming in and we need a better process
for screening those materials right a
building that's built on uneven terrain
or soft ground I will not get very high
similarly a building that has materials
with uneven quality so I'm going to sort
of rush through two aspects of this one
is sharing data
and how we change the norms around that
encode the second is pre-registration
and ways of thinking about it and I'm
going to try to get to the third very
quickly because I think it follows after
brian's talk in terms of thinking about
what's the future of science scientific
conversation that a platform like OSF or
others could build and could enable us
okay so we want scientists to share all
relevant files for understanding where
their knowledge claims come from right
that is practical ultimately I was
thinking when when Brian was talking you
know what is the Utopia of transparency
is it like a 1984 surveillance state
where we have cameras on and everything
I get shared 901 colleague of mine who
really wanted to live up to a
transparency norms posted in their
replication archive all the emails
between them and they're coders they
were sort of coding history so there was
you know thousands of emails and so any
critical reader can go and find out
exactly why was this historical
observation coded in this way and not
another way so so that might be the
limit my the transparency maximal offer
is that we should try to make every step
of research as explicit and reproducible
as is practical right clearly at some
point we're going to hit diminishing
returns or other constraints so we have
to leave it up to each discipline in
each researcher to negotiate that but
the benefits are are tremendous and I
mean Brian made most of these points one
I want to emphasize is the idea that
scientific publications used to be like
a scrapbook of photos of someone who
went on a vacation or travel and they
are showing us the pictures of their
journey and they're telling us a story
from that and that narrative is only as
good as we trust the author's
representation of what they saw and
there the analogy is to data whereas
with the internet with modern computing
we no longer need to have this static
representation of the data now I think
of the publication sorta like an
advertisement it's like a guided tour so
the authors say come with me reader I
will walk you
to a data landscape and show you what I
found and show you what's there but the
reader should be free to leave the tour
at any moment they can say I'm curious
about what's over that hill or what's
behind that you know curtain and they
should be in able to do that so I think
that's where we're going and yeah just
in terms of facilitating the
reproduction of analysis okay I'm just a
fun figure to share so I collected data
on these are the two leading political
science journals and the y-axis is the
proportion that state or whether the
article states that replication files
are available so if you take aways one
in the time period 2090 2013 at least if
we look at a PSR on the right which is
our number one journal it wasn't great a
dps on the other hand started out at
around zero and then jumps to about one
hundred percent and as you can probably
infer that's because a new editor came
on board and added a policy that says
all you know published a GPS articles
need the first footnote must state where
replication files are available so I
sort of a small commitment like that by
journal generated one hundred percent
compliance here's a letter of the law
but not the spirit so now the y-axis is
our replication files actually available
and nevertheless we still have 52 25% of
articles in a JPS despite a footnote
saying our replication files are
available here no replication files
could be found there or given about 10
minutes of searching anywhere else on
the internet hopefully I think the
community is adapting you know we see a
creep up and i should say political
science has really embraced transparency
norms and standards in part because of
the top sort of movement transparency
and openness promotion guidelines so
we're getting better but this is just a
show that you know it really helps to
have journals you know providing
incentives i'll skip that okay so you
know what what do we want incomplete
replication files you know we might want
even the emails between the p.i and the
lab members but i won't go that far i do
think we want
as far down in the sort of chain of
inference as possible and even think of
as we want to maintain a chain of
custody of how the original data led to
this final claim and then one other
point I just want to share that i think
is symptomatic of the state of at least
maybe political science but maybe other
social sciences is that I work with
surveys and survey experiments and a key
thing you want when you're reading a
survey is to see the original survey
text but the verbatim how how its laid
out the question that preceded the key
question right because you know text can
put the respondent in a different frame
of mind they interpret later questions
differently so we notice that this
matters a lot and yet to my amazement
leading scholars in my profession and my
discipline will publish surveys and
survey experiments without there's
nowhere on the internet is the actual
survey text available and so this is not
due to technical difficulties right it
is not hard to take a picture or a
screenshot or proof a PDF of your survey
or a QSF file for example to use
Qualtrics so I think what this reflects
is either a lack of appreciation of the
importance of this level of transparency
or people think they can get away with
it right with some combination of the
two so you know brian is great he builds
us tools to advance transparency I will
be a little bit more of the cynic or
realist I think we also need to stick
right it's here we don't need a tool to
get this happening we just need
colleagues to know it is not acceptable
to you know produce a surveyor server
experimental study and not share the PDF
publicly or what the text of this are
right okay and we could even make
stronger norms we could have journals
think that you should the paper should
be retracted if it can't be reproduced
from the original data and then of
course also it's where I mentioned we
should find ways of waiting transparency
in the incentive structure where it
matters we could rank and judge journals
and then when considering hiring and
promoting I'm
dollars we should up weight transparency
as a criterion okay so this is the
beautiful figure above the hundred
psychology studies and the main takeaway
here is you know some replicated they
the replicated effect was about the same
as the original effect but some many I
did not replicate they were the
estimated effect in replication was
around zero and this is this issue is
not addressed by what I've just been
discussing the sharing of code in data
because this could be due to publication
bias it could be due to the researcher
who runs 100 experiments and shares the
five that are most interesting right so
to address that we need pre-registration
or there's some other solutions and I
just want to flag a trade-off in cream
registration that unlike data sharing
and code sharing which i think is
unarguable there's very little sort of
cost to it with pre-registration in my
own experience and especially with my
students they there's a risk of spending
too much time at the pre-registration
taejun really slowing down other
research process those students will
because i'll give a very emphatic
lecture about the importance of
pre-registration they will spend a month
or two theorizing you know in designing
their study and then when they do what
they get a null right so that's a month
or two you know potentially wasted now
hopefully there's benefits but the main
point that I want to make is that a lot
of Sciences exploratory and inductive
that's it like a lot of the value that's
generated from science comes from the
exploratory inductive process so we just
need to find ways of preserving that
value and recognizing that it's valuable
at the same time as insisting that work
distinguishes whether it's confirmatory
exploratory by systematically doing
pre-registration and then the other
pitfall is that anticipating this time
cost scholars don't pre-register at all
so my recommendation is pre-register all
the time but don't don't require
yourself to have a perfect
pre-registration don't require it be you
know a fully fleshed theory necessarily
if you're not there
with full pre-analysis code I mean
that's great if you can do it but if
it's just one paragraph that's great and
OSF funds I understand as Brian's been
using it has sort of enabled that level
of different levels of sharing so you
might have a summary minutes from your
lab meeting and that would be a
pre-registration I think that's a good
compromise I know there's other ways
been no conventions that I think a good
way where you take up the treatment
variable and then you analyze your data
so then you get to see what the data
looks like and how how the outcome
correlates with various covariance but
you can't p hack because the treatment
variable is not connect to the outcome
so that's a promising way okay and I
might come back to that because you know
how much time I have five minutes okay
yeah so I want to get to this so this
speaks to Brian's later slides which are
so what's the future of scientific
conversation right and this idea that
publication and evaluation or currently
are intertwined and should be separated
is exactly right and I'll just sketch
sort of a vision that I think OSS is
moving towards and other groups are sort
of starting to build out the features
for this and I'll tell you the vision
that I think would be excellent and I
sort of think of an attractor for
scientific conversation and given how
many scientists we have here I would
love you know your thoughts that if this
makes sense so if i want to buy a book
here's Gelman and Hills data analysis
textbook I can go to the Cambridge
publishers website and what do I get I
get a title I get their author name I
get the price to cover art I can look
inside so I can actually read the whole
or much of the book but what I don't get
is what I start off by saying we need in
science which is the sort of synthesized
expert evaluation of my peers and
colleagues right I don't want to have to
read the whole book to decide whether I
should buy it I want to delegate to my
colleagues who have already read it
their judgment and then integrated in
some appropriate way we now have that
service amazon provides it for us these
aren't necessarily my colleagues who are
doing this with some time
they are but you have a community of
readers who volunteer time to share
their judgment and assessment of a book
not only you have the quantitative
ratings which is a useful way to screen
books but you also have a detailed
review in a holistic review amazon also
helpfully give those this what did these
customers who bought this also by which
is a useful service that currently well
at least the Cambridge website would not
provide so here's a an article from our
leading journal and again we get what
the publisher provides so we get the
sort of details to title the abstract
the author name but it's all shared it's
all provided by a self-interested group
the authors have a motivation to portray
the results in a certain light the
publishers have motivation to portray it
in a certain light there's no third
party here telling me you know what they
thought of this and so that's where I
think we want to go we want to build a
web platform or an online forum where
the community discusses works hopefully
expresses them in a quantitative metric
that can be aggregated in a sensible way
to facilitate my assessment of other
works so that I don't have to spend two
hours reading this paper to figure out
if I trust the results are not my
colleague who already did that can
basically tell me indirectly so we have
this more more efficient conversation
this already happens offline right if I
see I want to know if this works any
good I might email my colleague who I
know has read it and ask them for their
input so we just want to build a web
platform so that everyone has access to
that and it facilitates conversation so
here's one group that at least provided
sort of a visual representation of what
I think it could look like this is
science open here you have an article by
the same title authors I know maybe an
abstract and then what I'm really
looking for right is the quantitative
summary of what readers think of this
work and then you can imagine a holistic
review down here that's been uploaded by
all the readers so the first thing you
would see
is an expert judgment third party saying
this is what I think of this piece and
it's not just a troll or a negative you
know response it's someone who really
shares this is what this work achieves
and this is where it falls short these
are the scope conditions this is what's
impressive this is what you can look out
for when you're reading this right a
third party perspective that I can
quickly get to that's already been
crowd-sourced you know by the community
so that when i get there it's at the top
of visibility okay there's a lot of
things we could add to that and i'll
just list some so there's this idea of a
wiki abstract right rather than have the
authors who again have this self
interest and presenting the results as
being innovative and break out standing
I would love to share with what expert
reviewers think was actually achieved in
the paper right what did the results
actually show so more disinterested
representation the ratings could be
unimportant credibility clarity those
are three metrics that I think would be
useful you probably don't want just some
naive averaging over everyone's ratings
especially if it's really open to the
public right you wouldn't want to read
like climate science quantity of ratings
if a certain you know political group
decides to to get on there and downvote
all of them or even maybe one lab sort
of systemically down votes in other labs
work so you can have all kinds of
customized ratings where you might
subset on scholars of a certain
achievement or a certain like social
network entrepreneurs could even provide
the service I could say use my ratings
algorithm which pulls from I'm esteemed
respected scholars okay so then you'd
have the community would upload useful
contributions that's the first thing you
see like in Stack Exchange or reddit or
Korra or Amazon reviews is the sort of
overall most helpful assessment of the
piece but also contributors who are
systematically helpful would be uploaded
and then every subsequent contribution
that they make would be more likely to
be visible and conversely contributors
who are systematically
writing ad hominem things or unhelpful
comments would be downvoted and would
have difficulties getting visibility you
can have a range of anonymity so you
could though I think you'd probably want
each user to have some kind of
connection to an actual human identity
though you can work you could try with
an anonymous model but you could go all
the way to a signed model where everyone
has to use the real name though I
suspect given the prevalence of single
blind peer review at least in science
we'd probably want to preserve some at
least some kind of blinded mode so you
could login may you know make your
contributions under a pseudonym what the
editors would still know who you are and
so that would prevent kind of collusion
amongst you know circles of scholars who
are uploading or downloading their
rivals it would prevent it would help
you identify trolls and anyway I think
we'll just help keep the whole process
more productive and then last fun idea
that so throughout their for any metric
that is like social exogenous and really
verifiable as sort of either 0 or 1 you
could build a prediction market on to it
so the main of the obvious application
is replicability so if there's an
experiment that's done you could have a
prediction market for whether the
experiment would replicate according to
some standard replication and if if well
there's various ways but if the
replication is ever done according some
standard by perhaps by some consortium
of labs then the prediction market would
pay out so I think you know it's
inevitable that science will go to
something like this there will be a much
richer conversation in five and ten
years online I I can imagine it matters
how we what how we get there but I
imagine there's path dependence if we
get there if the scientists owned the
platform it could be more productive
than if a private company owns the
platform and the culture that we
establish going in so yeah I look
forward your thoughts and if anyone's
really interested in this I'd love to
talk with you afterwards
[Applause]